southern nevada water customers may not
even know it but were all part owners in
a vast ranching operation hundreds of
miles outside the las vegas valley
ranchers in east central nevada say they
are being bullied and run out of
business by a ranching competitor with
unlimited resources namely the
government george knapp of the eye team
has the story
they're bullying me
they're pulling all this kind of crap
which they have no right to do they're a
state agency for guy's sakes
rancher hank vogler and his sheep have
survived brutal winters extended drought
predators poachers you name it but
bogler isn't sure he can survive the
ongoing onslaught from one of his
neighbors the southern nevada water
authority snwa has spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on a failed plan to
siphon billions of gallons of
groundwater from rural nevada and ship
it to las vegas via a 15 billion dollar
300 mile long pipeline as part of that
plan the agency spent close to a hundred
million dollars to buy up at inflated
prices large ranches in white pine
county the plan was demolished in
federal court largely because removing
the groundwater would create a dead zone
in central nevada and the plan was
officially declared dead this is my life
but bogler suspects the actions against
him mean the water grab is still on the
table
and i think they're just trying to hold
their deal together and maybe long term
they think they're going to be able to
build the pipeline none of this makes
any sense for years vogler was one of
the most outspoken critics of the water
grab now he thinks he's being targeted
for payback there have been multiple
clashes between longtime ranchers and
the properties operated by snwa vogler
says snwa has filed for additional water
permits including the same ones he's
used to raise sheep for the past 21
years he suspects snwa is behind the 28
thousand dollar fine imposed on him by
the blm for trespassing that is for
using the water that's been his since
2000. i get a 28 000 willful trespass
they're trying to put 50 years of my
life out the window
they're trying to destroy my business
vogler alleges that snwa personnel
vandalized his water system disabled the
pumps poked holes in his troughs and
left his sheep to die they tore out my
water troughs they dismantled
the
control box on a well they knocked holes
in waterfronts george if you and i did
that
we'd be in charlie manson's cell bugler
says it's not just his ranch in the
crosshairs but others are being targeted
as snwa's ranch expands its operations
the legal bills are already draining him
dry while snwa has a huge legal team
funded by water customers in las vegas
why is a state agency in the ranching
business at all vogler says that federal
policies prohibit government agencies
from getting grazing permits but snwa
has them the great basin water network
says the intent is obvious quote snwa
maintains its massive farming and
ranching operation for one reason to
export water for sprawl growth in las
vegas at the expense of communities and
the environment vogler says state
agencies shouldn't be allowed to drive
people like him out of business they
have no business
in direct competition with private
enterprise raising sheep cows or alfalfa
george knapp 8 news now
now a spokesperson for snwa bronson mack
told us late today that snwa believes it
is eligible to receive grazing permits
given the blm has approved such permits
over the years he adds there are no
plans to pump any water to las vegas
from the authority owned properties